vous vous souvenez que casimir voulait
partir en bateau pour voir ses cousins
malheureusement une panne de moteur l'a
empêché de partir alors casimir a trouvé
une façon d'imaginer son voyage
voilà à mon pas l'âme
d'un
[Musique]
chantier naval
vous ne pouvez pas faire attention à la
pancarte a pesé trotta kazemi au jeu les
prises dans l'oeil mais que se
passe-t-il aux pasties les biens
ouvrez-les envoyez vous verrez le
radeau ben oui c'est pas un éléphant
mais comment at il atterri ici il n'a
pas atterri je les ai fabriqués grâce à
votre livre et je pars dans un instant
tu piques mais ses batteries c'est pas
très prudent tu sais casimiro laventure
ce n'est jamais prudent c'est vous qui
me l'avait fait comprendre
aux ben voilà julie françois le facteur
jeu sera question de raisonner au fait
que regarder mais que se passe-t-il ici
alors qu'en pensez vous mais c'est un
râteau il est très jolie n'est ce pas
pouvait il a l'air solide
bien je parle dans un instant et je
voudrais que vous m'aidiez à transporter
jusque jusqu'à la mer mais mais mais
casimir casimir attendait de rim il en
est pas question tu n'as jamais navigué
de ta vie bah ouais et alors mais les
navigateurs qui paraissent elles ont
derrière eux des années d'expérience
rôle mais moi je sais toute la
navigation grâce au livre de monsieur du
snav sol sur l'océan j'ai tout appris
j'ai d'ailleurs déjà écrit mon livre de
bord déjà si vous voulez le lire on
regarde moi je vais voir si je connais
quelque chose de la navigation
premier jour embarquement tous mes amis
sont venus me dire au revoir à monter
sur le banc et imaginer que celle-là je
t'ai
dis moi est ce bien nécessaire mais je
ne voulais pas jouer le jeu comment
pouvez vous savoir si je suis capable de
naviguer ou non ah oui tu as raison
alors
envoyez moi la marque atari
fait
là
la météo est bonne
le vent est favorable
je pars au revoir
ne parle pas un requin que tu ne connais
pas la jeter s'éloigna rapidement toutes
les villes
quand soudain au milieu de cette
première journée ce fut le calme plat la
voile ont des lamentablement le long du
mans
plus de van cau faire souffler dans la
voile
c'est fatigant à inutile attendant que
ça passe le deuxième jour deux dauphins
la campagne un petit moment monsieur du
snav et factor voulez-vous venir faire
les dauphins et je ne sais pas si je
saurai que moi et me faites comme moi
tenez gentil petit dauphin attraper ces
bonbons aux globules gare alors qu'elle
passait encore de faire les dauphins
mais en plus mon jeu des bandes horrible
que je te remercie et moi je crois phare
et quelques rondelles de saucisson sac
rose là je suis désolé mais j'ai déjà à
manger toutes mes provisions les
gracieux marsouin
après une pirouette dhabi
s'éloigne du radeau au revoir marsouins
soudain une terrible tempête se lève
j'apprends voile
si talent une gigantesque au bar
arrachement
japon gens continuent et jeunes mamans
pour être franc dans les vagues
hu
je continue à la pagaie
m'efforce s'épuise
je suis seule perdue au milieu de cette
immense océan au au secours à l'aide à
la ddt
je suis perdu
[Musique]
alors oui commandant ah bon tout de
suite très bien jarry j'arrive
pékin sur coty du temps réel si c'était
passionnant oh oui que s'est-il passé
ensuite ça n'a plus aucune importance
le commandant vient de m'appeler pour me
dire que le casimir aux premiers étaient
réparés et qu'il appareillait d'un moins
d'une demi-heure au formidable casini je
suis prêt je te suis on y voit un bon je
suis vraiment désolé françois mais il
m'a également dit que la cabine que nous
avions réservé pour nous deux était
juste assez grande pour moi tout seul
c'est demain je moi qui me faisais une
joie à l'idée de cette carte croisière
tant pis écoute si tu veux vraiment
revenir sur l'île voisine j'ai une
solution à te proposer ah oui laquelle
avec morado je te le prêt est à
casimir